you work Charlie in the Chocolate  Factory last night how much fun did you  find that it was wonderful we were with  our 10 year old son and surrounded by  lots of other children and it was a  wonderful memorable delightful evening  and we were especially proud of our  friends Marc with Marc Marc Shaiman it's  got women who wrote music and lyrics and  same Monday's our friend who directed it  it was a wonderful wonderful night  thrilling what if yells have you and  enjoying while you've been here in  London just all the sort of usual  suspects you know the tourist sites that  my children hadn't seen yet and and the  city which we have always thought was  really extraordinary and we always feel  so lucky to be visiting  you